[Music]
Khloe Kardashian is devastated following
reports that her boyfriend Tristan
Thompson has allegedly cheated on her
that according to a source close to the
Kardashian family who also tells ET
Tristan is a man khloe built a life with
and saw as her forever on tuesday
multiple outlets published photos and
videos that allegedly showed the NBA
player being intimate with several
unknown women and it's moving really
fast for me
now our source says Khloe's family is
rallying behind the reality star who is
due to give birth to her first child any
day it's just all like weird what's
happening I think it's just like you're
growing a humid quote Chloe's mother
Chris flew to Cleveland to be with her
and support her in whatever she needs
the rest of the family has been in
communication with Chloe and supporting
her they are working on seeing her ASAP
I've taught my kids from day one you
know family's everything so that comes
first
as for Chloe and Tristan's relationship
the source says quote the future is up
in the air the most important thing is
Chloe having a healthy pregnancy et has
also learned the Kardashians are
currently filming Keeping Up with the
Kardashians and multiple sources close
to production tell ET producers of the
show will soon determine how the alleged
cheating scandal will play out on future
episodes
[Music]
[Applause]